تداول رواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي مقطع
فيديو للحظه محرجه تعرض لها ميسي عند
وصوله الى الصين برفقه بعض لاعبي منتخب
بلاده استعدادا لمباراه وديه حيث فوجئ
ميسي بمنع ضابط الشرطه دخوله المطار بسبب
خطا في جواز سفره وبعد قرابه ساعتين من
الانتظار سمحت له السلطات الصينيه بالدخول
وفقا لتقارير صحفيه
ارادت رخصه القياده فحطمت السياره في
الارجنتين قررت سيده مسنه في عمر 63 بان
تحصل على رخصه قياده لكن الامر كاد ان
يودي بحياتها حيث اظهر مقطع فيديو التقطته
كاميره مراقبه اصطدامها بعمود اناره بشكل
عنيف خلال اختبار السياقه ما ادى الى تحطم
المركبه وتم نقل السيده الى المستشفى بعد
اصابتها بجروح طفيفه
[موسيقى]
اظهر مقطع فيديو على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي اسرابا من النحل تغزو سماء
من المره والسياح ما استدعى رجال الشرطه
للتدخل واغلاق الشوارع حتى لا يتعرض
الموجودون في المكان للخطر وظهر مربو
النحل وهم يجمعونه
وفي مصر اثر فيديو الجدل مجددا حول
المتسولين ويظهر فيه العثور على حوالي
مليوني جنيه داخل حوش كانت تعيش فيه احدى
المتسولات بعد وفاتها بعشره ايام في
محافظه قنا بسعيد بصعيد مصر وكانت
المتسوله وتدعى خيريه دائمه التجوال
والجلوس امام المحالي التجاريه للتسول وقد
جمع الثروه كبيره بلى من المال
[موسيقى]
كان هذا كل شيء لليوم لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات